- [Mark] All right Briana.
- [Briana] Yes.
Briana, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [Briana] San Fernando Valley.
- [Mark] And tell me about your childhood.
You had both of your parents as a kid?
- No. I grew up in foster care
from 14 months old, till 10.
And I got adopted at 10.
And-
I got adopted into like a-
She was a Catholic woman,
like a school teacher,
like totally different from my real mom
who was like a prostitute,
like a Heroin addict.
And like, you know, so
it was kind of like,
I don't know, the bloodlines
were different, you know.
- [Mark] Very different personalities.
- Yeah. Yeah.
(chuckles)
Like day night.
- [Mark] And how was your,
how would you describe your childhood.
- Foster care?
I mean, it was everything that
you hear about it you know.
Like,
like all the bad stories, you know.
But, at a young age I
learned that if I wasn't like
unsure about a place that
I could like run away.
So I ran away a lot, in Foster care.
- [Mark] What was the worst thing
you had to go through yourself?
- There was this one
family that would dose us
like he doses wife with whatever he had
and he dose us, like the girls and boys.
And like, you know, like have
his way with us, whatever.
And I was like stuck there
for like six months because,
like he was told that I ran away a lot.
So I had to be like escorted to school,
and like, all that shit like that,
like, it was fucked up.
- [Mark] So a lot of it, sounds
like a lot of sexual abuse.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Does that continue
with other families?
- I mean, yeah.
Like, I don't know.
A lot of it happened when I was sleeping.
So like now, like I sleep
really deep, you know.
I guess that happens,
like when you're a child,
and you go through that, like
you tend to block it out.
Like you fall too into deep sleep,
like when you're sleeping now.
So-
that kinda sucks you know,
when you're on the streets.
(chuckles)
- [Mark] What age were you when you,
started working the street?
- I was 16.
- [Mark] 16.
And where was that?
- That was in LA, Salle Central.
- [Mark] Salle Central?
- Hmm.
- [Mark] I figure out.
- [Mark] And where do you work today?
- Well, today, like, I
mainly like, do like calls.
Like, I don't really have like a pimp.
I kinda just do my own thing.
I mean,
I went from making like
a couple hundred bucks
to making like a couple thousand bucks.
So, that's way better. Yeah.
- [Mark] But you work like
in the Valley as well?
- Hmm, Yeah.
- [Mark] And suppurative?
- Yeah
- [Mark] And you've
worked with a pimp before?
- Yeah. But like I said, I ran away a lot.
So like, that only
lasted for about a week.
(chuckles)
I really like listening.
- [Mark] Yeah.
Have you had some bad
things happen to you?
- Yeah
- [Mark] In this lifestyle?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] What kind of stuff have you?
- I mean, like getting,
like jerked, you know.
Like getting beat up, getting,
I mean everything that
you can like, grab my hair
and like pull me in the
car, like stuff like that,
like it's, you know fucked up.
But nobody really thinks
about that when it's like,
you live that kind of lifestyle, you know.
- [Mark] You've been arrested before?
- Yeah. I've done three terms.
Yeah.
- [Mark] What for?
- Assault with a deadly weapon,
and GTA's in identity theft.
- [Mark] Oh, really?
- Hmm.
- [Mark] Do you have kids?
- I do.
- [Mark] How many kids?
- One child.
- [Mark] One.
And where's your, where's your child?
- He's out in Palm Springs.
I just got out last April.
I've been off for a
year for the first time.
I have like, no parole, no probation,
for the first time in like 13 years.
So, that's cool.
And like,
I got 50-50 with his guardian.
But, he's like gonna be 11 in September.
So-
- [Mark] Are drugs a part of your life?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] What's your drug?
- I do Heroin. I do Crystal.
I do Sherm. I do Weed.
I do, pretty much everything.
Xanax, all that good stuff.
- [Mark] And when did that start for you?
- I started doing Heroin 13 years ago.
And, I started it by snorting it.
And then, slamming it and,
smoking it and slamming it, slamming it.
(chuckles)
- [Mark] Yeah.
What do you think helps you
to survive this lifestyle?
It's a dangerous life, right?
- Yeah. It is.
- [Mark] You get depressed at times.
- Yeah, definitely.
I mean, I take a, like four Xanax a day.
I have a prescription for them.
So, that kind of like, just
numbs me out, you know.
That's pretty much what,
I think keeps me alive.
(chuckles)
- [Mark] Are you making money?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] You save money?
- Barely. I'm really
bad at spending money.
- [Mark] How do you
think working the streets
has affected you or changed you?
- I mean,
it's definitely made me learn
how to like fight for myself.
Like, I mean-
- [Mark] Are you even fighting
for yourself since you were?
- Yeah. You know, like since I was baby.
So, it's like I grew up in the streets.
Like, they like raised
me to who I am today.
And like, I don't know.
- [Mark] Your entire life has
been tough it sounds like.
- Yeah, definitely.
Yeah.
- [Mark] If you could
change one thing about it,
what happened to you, as in
your life, what would it be?
- Well, when I was 14 months old,
my mom was like the main
connect right there,
and I'm seven and a valley.
And she was like woke,
like, she was like the main person.
And they had like a Stash house
and it just so happened that I was
at that Stash house, on a
specific day with her friend.
And that day it got like
shot up, like shot at.
And like the bullet flew over my head
and went into his rib cage.
And like, the cops were called.
And they went inside and found everything.
And that's when my mom went to jail
for like seven years and everything.
And when she got out, like she
couldn't find me, you know.
So,
but I found her when I was
15, when I got pregnant.
- [Mark] Are you even able to stand back
and look at your life and say, man,
what a crazy lifestyle this is?
Or because you've lived
it, since you were a kid.
- It's honestly just
like normal to me now.
Like, I mean, like, I
don't, it's hard when, like
you don't have a direction and security.
And you don't know like how
to take the steps to get
to like bigger and better things.
You know, it's just like
a reoccurring circle.
It's just going and going
and going and going like a hamster wheel.
(chuckles)
- [Mark] How far did you go in school?
- [Briana] I actually
got my GED when I was 16.
So-
- [Mark] Okay.
Yeah when I was pregnant.
- [Mark] You've been in love before?
- [Briana] Ummm, yeah.
Yeah jail comes in between
your relationships.
So, that's not really
something to think about.
- [Mark] And your child, do
you talk to them sometimes?
- [Briana] Yeah. I talk
to him every night.
I play PS3 with him every night,
World War II, 3 I mean, World War 3.
- [Mark] Do you think your self-worth
plays a part in the
decisions she make in life?
- [Briana] Yeah.
Definitely I mean like,
you know, when you grow up
like not really having,
anybody to like
love on you or show you
anything, like, you know.
You kind of just like,
don't learn about that.
You don't have that.
So it's like, you don't really invite it
cause you don't know what
it's like to have that.
So it's like, when it is there,
you don't know what to do with it.
So it kind of scares you a little bit.
So like you push away more.
- [Mark] Yeah, you never
had any role models too?
- [Briana] Yeah, exactly.
- [Mark] To emulate.
What advice would you
give to some young girl
who's got a similar situation,
and she's considering doing this kind of-?
- Go to school and get your diploma.
And go to college and take
every chance you can get,
with somebody that can help you.
(chuckles)
Yeah.
Like I mean, I've been-
I've done three terms and like
it's really easy for a convict,
I guess, to go to school.
I just found out like a couple of days ago
like they take you through
everything and like
pretty much everything's
paid for and everything.
And like, I didn't know that
until a couple of days ago,
and I'm 26 and I've been going
to jail since I was like 18.
- [Mark] Have you ever
had anyone in your life,
who truly just wants the best for you?
- Ummm, my son.
I think my son. Yeah.
- [Mark] Yeah.
Where do you hope to be in the
next, like five years or so?
- Hopefully,
somewhere different than where I'm at.
Like, this is the first time in 13.
Like I said, 13 years at like
I have no tail or like no
parole and probation or nothing.
So like, it's like a somewhat normal life.
Like I could have a normal life,
if I really tried and really wanted to.
And really tried to get
that, you know, like.
Because jobs like don't hire, you know,
like convicts and you got
probation, shit like that.
Like, but this is the
first time that I'm like
not on any of that stuff.
So-
- [Mark] How old are you?
- I'm 26
- [Mark] 26, so you still
have plenty of time?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- [Mark] What would help you the most
to change direction, right now?
- Probably a detox place.
(chuckles)
- [Mark] To get clean?
- Yeah. Honestly
- [Mark] You using a
lot of different drugs.
- Yeah. I mean Heroin is like, you know,
it's, you become a slave to it.
And like, you can't
really think about a job
or like any kind of lifestyle.
And like, you have to have
something like, and it's you-
it's hard to get money for that.
Like you have to have it.
- [Mark] It becomes your
first priority, right?
- Yeah, exactly. Like-
- [Mark] More than your job?
- Yeah like, I mean, like
a couple of years ago,
Cause I was using the needle
for like six years or something
and,
I fell in love,
and the person that I fell
in love with didn't
like Heroin or slamming.
And like, I remember
I had just gotten into
a bad car accident and he like,
let me stay at his house and everything.
And like this one day, I just
like, cause I couldn't move
cause of the car accident.
And I was trying to hit, like,
I just kinda like broke
down and started crying.
And he like told me that
he would help me get off.
So like I did, I switched
from slamming to smoking.
And like, I don't know.
That was a big thing for me.
Like, I never stopped slamming for myself,
or my kid or anybody, you know,
like that wasn't an option.
It didn't seem like.
- [Mark] What does your
typical day look like?
- Uuum,
well,
going in,
getting as much money as I possibly can,
and going and getting a room,
then the next morning you have checkout
and then you have to pay more money.
And, it's like, if I just saved
all the money that I made,
I could probably be a billionaire now.
(chuckles)
- [Mark] So you make a lot of money
but you spend it on drugs and hotel rooms.
- Yeah. Yeah
- [Mark] Things like that?
- Yeah.
And it's crazy out there in the streets.
Like you definitely
don't wanna be out there.
Like, between the cops and the people.
Like they're both all bad.
(chuckles)
Like-
So, yeah getting a room is like necessary.
Like you have to have a room
and you can't like live off
with somebody else, you know?
- [Mark] So you're living in hotel rooms?
- Yeah
- [Mark] Just going from hotel to hotel?
- Yeah. Room to room, yeah.
- [Mark] And you use it to bring clients,
- Hmmm.
- [Mark] As well as a place to sleep.
- Yeah.
Yeah.
- [Mark] And what do you,
if you could have anything,
what do you wish could
come into your life?
(indistinct)
- [Mark] Yeah. I'll ask that again.
I can edit this together.
Sorry about that.
- Hmmm.
- [Mark] So if you
could get a lucky break,
like something great could happen for you,
what would you love that to be?
- The lottery would be awesome.
(chuckles)
A vacation would be awesome.
- [Mark] If you probably use a break
from all this right?
- Yeah, definitely.
I mean, it's been going
on for so long, you know,
it's kinda hard to
remember what it's like not
with it in my life, you know?
- [Mark] All right, Briana.
Thank you so much for talking with me.
- You're welcome.
- [Mark] Good luck with
getting back with your son.
- Thank you.
- [Briana] Cut
(chuckles)